merci bien tu es bien tu es bien kucera
côté dit luc skate avec
hélas ce matin je lis mes filles parce
que bon je prépare pas trop les missions
ch2o et j'ai dû nouveau chroniqueur
julie cyril comme ça je dis pardon gelé
laurent hanouna
hanouna ouais ça rapport avec le salaire
et non il dit quelque chose j'appelle la
prod on dit stan homonyme ça peut
arriver on me dit non c'est son cousin
oui oui vous êtes deux cousins de cyril
hanouna complètement mais vous êtes très
bienvenus
bien installé à wissant et la satim et a
fait un beau public
ouais un animateur incroyable mais
marolles tout ce qui est dit
[Applaudissements]
une boisson en turquie chose mais rabat
laurent
non si tu veux animé d'une foi tout le
monde tu prends ma place jamais vraiment
jamais quelle foule à olhao démarre je
démarre et
et j'ai envie de bien la créature
envoyer ton cv pour arriver ici
c'est pas moi c'est pas mon truc a fait
ça va être bon made in big ben est pas
content syrie si les rétrocommissions ip
son cousin ça revient sa famille
mais a plus que lui alors vous êtes
magnifique je peux vous demander votre
âge
dany coquet gala compliquer à l'avenir
en tête piquée c'est une marge et c'est
payant 50 un peu plus de 50 60
mais quand même
que ça vaut pas 60 non
marc à eux
c'est bien nunaa
il nous a quand même tout une taupe dans
l'équipe quand même te
rassure vous faites quoi dans la vie
sinon qui moi aujourd'hui rentier
j'imagine comment apporteurs d'affaires
dorian olivier j'adore ça ah ouais les
lésions corse et 12 ils tueraient import
export tu vague apporteurs d'affaires
mais vous apportant l'immobilier à vous
apporter des adhésifs et je mets des
gens contactent exactement vous mettez
déjà en contact pour l'immobilier auprès
d'accor donc vous chantiez vous trouvez
les appartements vont servir aux métiers
à l'accord signé à quoi d'accord j'étais
pendant 25 ans fabricant de
prêt-à-porter féminin non j'ai habillé
les femmes eh
bien écoutez c'est par hmida ben
franchement c'est très heureux de vous
avoir laurent j'ai pas une chambre jeu
très heureux